I can't say Korean slurs but you know
people can rap songs can use the n-word
mm-hmm
that's racist I should be able to use
the G word well as Don Lemon said seven
years ago they should stop using that
word
I mean so I'm just going off what he
said right now I'm just saying what
about my rights to use the G word I had
a conversation with a Korean person
about this who was I don't even know
what the G word is I can't say it I
don't even know I don't think I know
actually you know what I got I got to be
honest I'm willing to bet that youtube
doesn't even know the G word is either
really bad I bet I'm not gonna say
anything I'm waiting I'm waiting for
chat to explode on what it is if all I'm
seeing is what's that what is it if good
I don't I don't know if because YouTube
blocks a bunch of words okay I actually
had a conversation with a Korean person
about this about whether or not we are
allowed to say it and the agreement was
yeah of course
and I was like even me cuz I'm mostly
white you know but like my family is
part Korean and they were like oh yeah
for sure definitely okay they see it
well yeah there's many many chat people
that have figured out what it is yeah
yeah yeah so alright I tell you what man
I'd be willing to bet that if you went
out in public and asked strangers to say
like you read these words and you wrote
like bicycle you know machine-gun
elephant G word G word they would just
say it
yeah they would just say it and you'd
really like thank you for the give a
recording of that person pre on a racial
slur so there was actually uh I was I
was I was actually I'm gonna keep this
one relatively vague but I was talking
to some friends and I brought up the
fact that most people don't know any
racial slurs outside of like the n-word
for instance and these the S word and
slaughter flares and I was like so what
would happen if you went to like
Starbucks and they asked your name and
you gave him like a racial slur for a
race that Americans don't care about
like Koreans like I'm pretty confident
if I went to Starbucks and they asked
for my name and I said the G word say
they were just dial it out dr. G no no
if I said my name is you know G word no
they would write it on they would write
it down and then someone would make my
Pacino they grab it and go and just yell
it out is there a G word your
frappuccinos ready no they would go woke
up G word G word and I'd be like whoa
whoa whoa dude are you kidding me what's
guys hurts throwing stuff and flipping
tables fun and then you film it and boom
got you Starbucks yeah but I was Lionel
catalyst Arbor the point I was making
was that Americans only care about some
minorities they don't care about Asians
same with space of course that's their
argument now what well they don't want
all free speech they just want their
free speech they say they're for free
very specific speech they they're
approved speech what they've actually
they've argued we're actually in favor
of free speech free speech because when
marginalized voices are oppressed then
they can't speak so by banning hate
speech you actually protect free speech
and I'm like do you not free speech
means like anybody can get their
thoughts and opinions through it so you
can't ban speech and claim it's free
speech mm-hm that's not real yeah
there's a there's a very very solid line
between having all free speech and not
having free speech and if you if you ban
anything that's not free speech at all
boom there's it's it's black and white
yep can I say that anymore
probably not we're like we you know the
cliffs are eroding yeah you know that's
why I described it when they when they
start banning more and more people James
Lindsay you mentioned this before we
started the show conceptual James he was
just he just was I'm Joe Rogan you know
gained a bunch of followers cuz he's
talking about intersectional ISM he
pushes back hard and they suspended his
Twitter account for no reason he's a
what is he a math PhD yeah he's a math
PhD tweeting like here's how
intersectionality and woke ism worked
and they're like suspended whoa whoa
whoa we can't have people understanding
what's going on no that's true they
can't that's exactly why I said free
speech yeah I'm gonna take that as you
telling me I was right you all right you
are correct sir oh it's like the sun
shining on me no but the thing about the
racial slurs I thought was really funny
is I was like you could very easily make
a
a whole montage of all of these
different chain restaurants their
employees yelling racial slurs because
they wouldn't know what the words meant
I was I was thinking about it because I
was watching South Park you ever see
that episode of South Park where they go
to the was it the intolerance museum is
that what it was yeah I think so and
like they're like we don't tolerate
intolerance but they go through this
tunnel where it just spouts a whole
bunch of racial slurs okay and what was
interesting to me about is I didn't know
I don't know 90% of the words mm-hmm
like if you watch it's like a bunch of
words and I have a friend of mine who's
Italian and he pointed I was like oh
yeah they're making fun of Italians and
I was like I never heard that well I
didn't know that and so I actually
sarted asking people and they don't know
anything in fact like the slur for
Hispanic people and most people don't
know yeah I mean you can't say anything
don't say I was just gonna say that I I
think for the most part because they
don't they don't know them because most
people aren't racist anymore yeah it's
just they don't know them
most people are racist anymore people
are just like oh yeah oh are you a cool
person cool do you know how I mean I
really I know I know like probably all
of the racial slurs for Asian people cuz
probably it's pi could have I grew up
and what do you race this or something
because because Asians are super racist
oh no you had your buddy man who was
like oh yeah you're you're this racial
slur oh yeah this racial apartment of my
neighborhood but we thought it was
hilarious
you know those I don't know the context
when I was growing up there's one kid
who just would call everybody by their
racial slur and it meant literally it I
would say it meant nothing to us like it
didn't affect us yeah but I would say
was actually a net positive because it
was basically like the ultimate
diversity yeah an inclusion it was like
listen when we're here together
skateboarding as friends yeah we are all
equally racial slurs
so did he talk in the third person to
like know whatever his whatever he would
have been I don't know well like you
pointed out if someone told him yeah he
would just yell it and like whoa don't
call me by my name call me this racial
slur that leaks me perfectly look I want
to be included too of course why people
have racial slurs a whole bunch of [ __ ]
all the different white people but we
grew up with with South Park and Family
Guy and all these jokes so everybody
loved it and and George Carlin
no you know where he got it from he got
it from George Carlin doing the bit
where he said all the waiters he just
goes off and he memorized them all and
so we all grew up like urban liberal
Chicago
you're watching George Carlin mm-hm and
so that and n South Park and so it was
hilarious when we'd be out skating and
then he just start Malvin off and yeah
it's funny I know and what he did the
best of is he
he took the power away from it he took
took away the the hate out out of it
in a weekend and well no there
everyone's bringing it back there
they're empowering all these words
they're bringing it back there they're
making it that it is a hate thing
instead of you have no power here
anymore because we have thick skin we
have spines we know who we are we don't
let that affect us anymore that's that's
we're losing that it's worse they fired
the guy from Papa John's for complaining
about it you know did you hear the story
I did hear it I will not talked about it
I mean us I am NOT one to get overly
like like chick-fil-a I don't care man
if I feel like any chicken sandwich I'm
going you know chick-fil-a was doing
this this donations to like Christian
groups and I said I don't care and then
they canceled the house like I don't
care and they started pandering to the
far left and I'm like I still don't care
man yeah like all of these companies do
different things I tell you what though
Papa John's I will never eat Papa John's
again that crossed the line Papa John
the original on a phone call oh gee and
he was complaining that Colonel Sanders
used the n-word and and no one said
anything about it and that was his
complaint he was like you know you get
Colonel Sanders and he said and he
actually used the full N word but to
complain about it and then somebody on
the call leaked it to Forbes or
something and then they forced him out
of the company they pulled his name off
University his company his company this
is the most insane canceled culture I've
ever seen that you were literally
agreeing and complaining about someone
getting away with using the word and
they take your name off of a building
where you've donated all this money yeah
I think ridiculous they like try to
destroy his life why he didn't even
disagree with them man all right you
know what the guy at Netflix know this
is the this is probably the best cancel
culture example let me just tell all of
y'all listening
right now there are a bunch of threads
going around on Twitter where they're
like cancel culture isn't real and
there's one going viral where they're
like if you've been canceled
you need to atone for your wrongs and
earn back the respect okay an executive
over at Netflix was giving it was having
a discussion about why Sir about what
words were offensive and could not be
used and so he started explaining people
here are some examples of words you
can't use and he said them and someone
in the meeting went he actually said it
and they went to HR and they said he
said the word so they brought him into
HR and Assam what happened and as he was
describing the incident he said the word
again and then someone in the HR meeting
he said the work to us if item he was
saying I was telling people that these
words are offensive and we can't have
them on Netflix words like and then you
list them off yeah and then they you
know started all panicking and crying
and hiding in the corner screaming that
they were under a violent assault by
this man and so they have to go back to
you know writing notes and passing them
around these are the words that you must
omit from your vocabulary the Q word you
know this is this is the thing we're
both from Chicago I know you know you
know him he's from Chicago oh yeah I'm
from Chicago too we're gonna talk about
a lot that's kind of how we do things
here at Tim cast we talk about Chicago
that we're from Chicago well one thing
about Chicago that you may or may not
know they love their pizza all right and
we know we know pizza in Chicago right
I'm all right oh yeah oh yeah so we know
pizza Papa John's
you don't make pizza I'm sorry no your
pizza sucks
all right I'm saying it so it's no loss
I I'm not even a big fan of Papa John's
if you want good pizza don't don't go
what's your favorite pizza Chicago
Don Dee's pizza Don DS yeah you might
not know it's at a small it's one it's
one down DS there's only one I work
there actually delivered pizzas for a
while one of my jobs is awesome you know
I still get all the time from big I
think was big lose in his yard and era
pizza ooh and I know that you guys
listening don't even know what jardin
air is Oh too bad
it is John I think that's a yeah yeah
it's weird but I'll just tell you as I
putting carrots and celery on your pizza
and get all the sounds weird but I mean
with pepper I love it
yeah so let's do this hold on before
before we do I wanted to bring this up
I'm actually seeing this a lot it's this
these lists that people are making of
businesses like Papa John's and even
Netflix I guess probably will make this
list of people that are like if you are
so weak willed to cancel people we're
not going to support you anymore yeah
I'm seeing this pop up more and more
it's like they're there now like ah yeah
basically they're there saying like
we're not gonna give this company our
money if they're gonna just cater to
this cancel culture essentially you know
and it's like it's becoming you know any
more prevalent you know I thought you
know I don't think that would work why
these companies already made their bed
knowing full well they'll lose the
conservative cash they made a calculated
decision before they published before
they got woke how much do we stand to
lose and how much do we stand to gain
and they chose a side well and they've
opted for the safe they think it's safer
to go left I do agree with that and it
because it is about the money and that's
not necessarily to say that that that is
gonna you know be fruitful for them you
know it there might come a chance or you
know a time where people actually enough
people make a huge dent and they're
going oh wow we're actually losing money
now because we mean decision parlor is
probably the best opportunity right now
for collective conservative action
mm-hmm because the user base is 99.9
percent you know conservative okay so it
would be really easy for anybody on
parlor you to be like echo this post so
that everyone on the site sees it and
send a message about X tax company so we
were talking months before like one of
the one of the things that conservatives
and now moderates who have a lot of our
you know aligned with conservatives on
free speech issues the reason why they
can't succeed against the left in many
of these culture war battles is because
the left has already been organizing for
decades they have email lists they have
large groups they're high-profile
Twitter accounts with huge followings
that are verified they put out one tweet
to a couple hundred thousand people hey
everybody hit up Verizon and tell them
you're in a boycott and they do and
Verizon panics conservatives don't do
that
imagine if there was a version of that
on say parlor and said everybody spend
ten seconds doing this that would be
that would that would cause these
companies to panic getting getting
getting from the left and the right
flank they'd be like what do we do yeah
how about we shut up and don't do
politics anymore
done think about if they put their
stupid little brand logo and bright
message here at brand we support group
of people and then also they got a huge
wave of like 200,000 comments being like
polite not hateful just saying we really
would respect you more if you didn't
engage in politics yeah look man you
deliver pizzas you know for my kids
birthday the last thing I need from you
was a lecture on my political opinions
you know us please give me pizza that is
a fantastic idea Tim wink wink for the
people who I just actually watching us
I'm not gonna do it you can do it I and
as easily as I can do it you can do it
too I'm talking to anyone who's
listening to me right now you can also
do this you know a lot of people have
come up to me like oh why haven't you
started this you know this email this
because I'm I'm spending most of my day
researching the stuff that's going on
you know it's like I if I started
focusing on just researching what
companies are canceling people that's a
very slim thing and I don't want that I
I'm trying to maintain a really broad
sense of the atmosphere of what's going
on in this country and I think that's
really important as being where I'm at
you know sitting next to you like I need
a broader you know sense of things so
it's not a you know and actually someone
you know kind of reamed us out like oh
you have this this skate park in your
backyard when you should be you know
spending money on you know organizing a
movement it's like do you not watch our
show do not know what we talked about we
you know this is the forum that we have
helping people learn how to speak have a
civil conversation even if you don't
agree you and that's okay
you know now people are questioning
whether they're not the show will last
it's like they clearly don't understand
the the friendship that you and I have
well they're like the questioning that
we argue on the show it's a show peple
and we just built a new four foot
quarter pipe and adam people at the
finals will you
the whole thing yeah and he threw down a
blunt blunt rock fakie first first
tricks could go right and I was where he
was gonna fall over because I wasn't
weighted and you just went for it anyway
yeah so now we have yeah we have
skatepark that's how I skate though
listen man I'm not I don't consider
myself to be overtly an activist I
consider myself to be politically active
on certain issues like freedom liberty
things like that and that's why I speak
out against it but I'm not a political
operative in that sense I don't go and
hang out with political groups to give
them advice on their political positions
and what they should or shouldn't do I
don't do it well that's why I said I'm
not gonna make an email list no hey you
can't add him if you'd like and it's not
something I do but this is this is kind
of the thing I'm talking about this is
the problem with a lot of what's going
on everybody expects someone else to do
the work yeah you all every single one
of you needs to do work we all need to
understand what's going on every single
person needs to get out and do the
research and understand what's happening
everybody it's on everybody we're all
humans we're all there we all want this
to to be better we all want to live
comfortably you got that's it what would
what would it have been like if if the
Planeteers never combined their powers
right their rings and and they're on a
Captain Planet no Captain Planet yeah it
was only when they realized that
together when they when they pointed
their rings in the sky they could summon
Captain Planet
yes yes Tim I'm spinning that's a that's
a spin for Tim I can't I couldn't think
of any of the bad guys from Captain
Planet loot and plunder plunder that was
the name right and that was that was
great that was a Ted Turner show Captain
Planet
you don't really annoyed me back Captain
Planet what they never they almost never
actually use it their rings on their own
like at a certain point like you can
have some personal responsibility too
you know like there'd be some episodes
you like sometimes they'd be like you
know wheeler would be like fire and
actually burn something yeah but I guess
the concern was that if he was like
going around burning people like the bad
guy shows up and he would even that they
weld on a minute if they're fighting
this big evil guy who's gonna pollute
this whole country and kill all these
people wheeler could walk up to a point
point bring in his face and go fire and
just alight the dude up yeah but they
never did and that's because violence is
not the answer
saying look man I'm sorry all right
I don't agree with I don't agree with
the death penalty but I do believe there
is a line you know people asking about
this like what if you're in combat
that's different so so I'm not a big fan
of Batman's no-kill policy because you
end up with that with the Justice Lords
timeline where the Joker ends up you
know drugging Superman Superman goes and
wipes out metropolis and all that stuff
and then he gets mad because Batman
could have stopped Joker if Batman would
just you know grow a pair Joker
literally kills millions of people at a
certain point like you can you can I
don't believe that after you subdued
somebody and lock them up that you can
then go about ending them but if
someone's literally on the verge about
to kill a bunch of people then and you
have to stop them by any means necessary
that I understand okay you know that's
just my point about no Batman yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
if you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you